.
COME JOIN US LIVE "AMERICAN
REPORTS" AT THE TOP OF THE HOUR.
>> ROLLING STONE IS ACCUSING
REPUBLICANS OF FEARMONGERING AND
IT IS CALLING RAINBOW FENTANYL
THREAT FAKE.
THE MAGAZINE RELEASING THIS
ARTICLE "NO TREATS, ONLY
TRICKS."
REPUBLICANS TRY TO RUIN THE
HOLIDAY WITH FAKE FENTANYL.
AND CONVINCED PARENTS THE
CARTELS ARE DOWN THE BLOCK
HANDING OUT SYNTHETIC OPIOIDS TO
KIDS.
THE ARTICLE WAS PUBLISHED AFTER
WE TALKED ABOUT A PSA ISSUE BY
12 REPUBLICAN SENATORS HERE ON
"OUTNUMBERED."
WATCH.
>> FAKE PILLS LACED WITH
FENTANYL ARE BEGINNING TO LOOK
LIKE CANDY IN AN EFFORT TO LURE
YOUNG AMERICANS.
>> RAINBOW FENTANYL COMES IN
SHAPES, SIZES, INCLUDING
PILLS, POWDERS, BLOCKS THAT
RESEMBLE SIDEWALK CHALK.
>> ACCORDING TO THE DEA, THESE
PILLS ARE DELIBERATE EFFORT BY
DRUG TRAFFICKERS TO DRIVE
ADDICTION AMONG KIDS AND YOUNG
ADULTS.
>> THIS EPIDEMIC IS
EXPLODING, WHICH IS WHY THIS
HALLOWEEN, LET'S JOIN FORCES AND
LOOK OUT FOR ONE ANOTHER.
>> WELL AND HE UNDERSTAND IT
COULD BE INCONVENIENT FOR
DEMOCRATS TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
FENTANYL CRISIS THEY ARE DOING
LITTLE ABOUT, HAS A MOTHER OF
THREE, I WORRY ABOUT IT.
KAYLEIGH, YOU HAVE YOUNG KIDS.
NO ONE IS SAYING THAT THE CARTEL
IS GOING HOUSE TO HOUSE
TARGETING THESE YOUNG ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL AGED KIDS.
NO ONE IS SAYING THAT, BUT LET'S
BE HONEST.
MISTAKES CAN HAPPEN AND WHEN YOU
HAVE YOUNG CHILDREN WITH
COLOR-CODED TABLETS ALL OVER THE
PLACE, YOU WAY THEY COULD EXIT
DO KNOW MIKE ACCIDENTALLY INGEST
THEM.
>> Kayleigh: 15,000 PACKAGES
OF SKITTLES AND NERDS WITH
FENTANYL AND THEM HERE AND HOW
DARE ROLLING STONES SAY THIS
WHEN YOU HAVE 27% OF TEENAGERS
WHO ARE AWARE OF FENTANYL CAN
MIX WITH ADDERALL OR SOME OTHER
MEDICATION.
THAT IS A SMALL PERCENTAGE AND
HEROIN IS MORE THAN FENTANYL.
THIS COULD CERTAINLY HAPPEN TO A
TEENAGER WHERE 13-YEAR-OLDS ARE
DYING BUT IN FACT THEY PUT
TOGETHER A PSA TO GET THE WORDS
OUT TO TEENAGERS, YOUNG
CHILDREN, PARENTS THIS IS
HAPPENING WITH FENTANYL ACROSS
THE BORDER.
MAN, WOMAN, CHILD WHEN DISTRICT
ATTORNEY SAID 90% OF THESE PILLS
THAT ARE BEING PURCHASED BY
TEENAGERS CAN CONTAIN FENTANYL.
GOOD JOB, REPUBLICANS GETTING
THE WORD OUT AND THAT ON
ROLLING STONES.
SPEAK DON'T >> HYPOCRISY IS
ASTOUNDING SAYING THIS IS
FEARMONGERING.
KENNEDY, AUGUST 2022, A RAINBOW
FENTANYL, FENTANYL PILLS THAT
COME IN A VARIETY OF SHAPES AND
SIZES AND EFFORT BY DRUG
TRAFFICKERS TO DRIVE ADDICTION
AMONG KIDS AND YOUNG ADULTS.
>> Kennedy: I DON'T KNOW, I
PUSH BACK ON THIS THIS WEEK AND
I WILL PUSH BACK NOW.
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT IS
NECESSARILY TRUE.
TALKING ABOUT THE STORY IN THIS
WAY IS A MASSIVE DISTRACTION
FROM AN OPIOID CRISIS KILLING
PEOPLE.
WHAT HAPPENS IS GOOD KIDS WHO
HAVE NEVER DONE ANYTHING LIKE
THIS COMIC THEY THINK THEY ARE
BUYING ECSTASY.
THEY THINK THEY ARE BUYING
COCAINE, AND THOSE ARE THE ONES
WHO ARE DYING.
THAT IS THE REAL PROBLEM HERE.
DRUG DEALERS HAVE ALWAYS DONE
THIS.
THEY HAVE ALWAYS REPACKAGE
THINGS IN ORDER TO GET THEM INTO
THE COUNTRY AND EVADE THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
I SAT IN EL CHAPO TRIAL.
AND PUTTING COCAINE AND TOMATO
CANS.
ACROSS THE BORDER, OH, EVERYBODY
LOVES TOMATOES.
THAT IS ESSENTIALLY WHAT THEY
DO, THEY PUT INSIDE CANDY AND IF
SOMEONE OPENS IT, THEY WILL SAY
MOVE ALONG, MOVE ALONG.
>> Dr. Saphier: MORGAN, TO
KENNEDY'S POINT, THE HALLOWEEN,
IN THE 1970s, EVERY YEAR AND
HALLOWEEN PEOPLE START SAYING
RAZOR BLADES OR SOMETHING IN THE
CANDY.
BUT THE TRUTH IS, SOMETIMES
THERE ARE.
IS IT AS BIG AS PEOPLE PLAY OUT
TO BE?
CAN IT BE IN A DISTRACTION FROM
THE FENTANYL OPIOID?
YOU DO HAVE THESE COLOR-CODED
TABLETS GOING ON AND PEOPLE ARE
ACCIDENTALLY OVERDOSING.
THEY ARE LOSING THEIR LIFE.
YOU DON'T THINK THEY ARE TAKING
FENTANYL AND THE ONLY SOLUTIONS
ARE PEOPLE SAYING, "WE NEED TO
TEST FOR FENTANYL BEFORE THEY
TAKE ILLEGAL DRUGS OR NARCAN."
WHAT ABOUT STOPPING THE ILLEGAL
MEDICATIONS, ILLEGAL DRUGS
COMING FROM THE BORDER?
>> HERE IS THE FACT THAT WE
KNOW.
FENTANYL IS THE NUMBER ONE
KILLER IN THE COUNTRY AND IT
TOOK 72,000 AMERICANS IN THE
PAST YEAR AND ANOTHER FACT IT
COMES FROM TIGHT TO MY CHINA THE
CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY KNOWS
THAT IT IS SHIPPED TO MEXICO.
WE KNOW IT IS A FACT THAT THE
CARTELS ARE MAKING BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OFF OF THIS AMP BECAUSE
WE HAVE AN OPEN BORDER THIS GETS
INTO THE COUNTRY.
THESE ARE ALL FACTS.
IF THE DEMOCRATS WANT TO BE MAD
AT ANYONE OR ROLLING STONE
META-ANYONE, BE MET THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST PARTY, CARTELS AND
PEOPLE IN CHARGE OF THE SOUTHERN
BORDER AND ALL OF THIS KILLING
YOUNG PEOPLE.
THAT IS WHO TO BE MAD AT.
>> ROLLING STONE SAID THE
FENTANYL CRISIS IS A MYTH.
>> Todd: MY PROBLEM WITH THIS
ARTICLE IS TWOFOLD, ONE, NOT A
MYTH.
THIS IS A REAL PROBLEM AND
PEOPLE ARE DYING AS APTLY
POINTED OUT.
BUT MY SECOND POINT, I HAVE A
DIFFERENT TAKE, I THINK.
I BELIEVE IN PARENTING AND I
LOVE TO HAVE A CONVERSATION.
NO, IF YOU GREW UP THE WAY I DID
IN AN ITALIAN AMERICAN HOUSEHOLD
IN NEW JERSEY, THERE IS NO
CONVERSATION.
YOUR PARENTS PUT THE FEAR OF GOD
A NEW.
THE REASON I NEVER THREW A PARTY
GROWING UP BECAUSE MY PARENTS
SAID, YOU THROW A PARTY, WE LOSE
THE HOUSE, WE LOSE THE HOUSE."
I HAD THE FEAR OF GOD FOR
SOMETHING THIS SERIOUS, STRIKE
THE FEAR OF GOD IN YOUR KIDS.
THEY COULD DIE WITH